What is it you think we do here?
I thought we were lifeguards--
What happened to that last pretty boy recruit?
He died.
Who's your daddy now?
Did you just look at my boobs?
I-
(Jumps up and down) Not here.
Here.
Welcome to Baywatch.
Hear for the qualifiers, one direction?
What is this? Life guard hazing?
*Yelps* You dick.
You turned the Canals into the X Games
We were in lifeguard pursuit.
Oh okay except there's no such thing as lifeguard pursuit!
You're going night night bitch
Welcome to baywatch
Our team is the elite of the elite.
We're the heart and soul of this very beach.
Come on Pete, make my pecks a little bigger and don't cover up my front bump.
You got it! Huge dick.
Big Dick.
Hey Little Mermaid, you here for the qualifiers?
I don't have to try out. I'm Matt Brody.
Two gold medals.
Hey! Matt Brody.
Yeah, we still don't give a-
Did you just look at my boobs?
Not here.
Here.
If you're gonna be on this team, one direction, you gotta earn it.
These having nothing to do with saving people. These are refrigerators.
This is Baywatch. You pussy!
(bell dings)
I get it. You're big sasquatch,
but I'm fast.
(yelps) Shit.
Drugs,
murder,
a dead body on our beach.
And it all started once she took over.
Some people are up to no good.
We're gonna have to do what Baywatch does best.
You're lifeguards, not police.
Splash, spalsh.
Damn!
Why does she always look like she's running in slow-mo?
She's the reason I believe in god.
Yes!
We gotta go undercover! But where the hell is Brody?
How come you're wearing makeup, dude?
What do you mean, why am i wearing makeup? Its a little much. I look legit. Hot.
(inaudible)
Move, move, move!
Jason Bourne ain't got shit on me!
Go, go, go!
Why are we in the morgue?
We gotta get some hard evidence.
Someone's coming!
What do we do now?
Now we hide.
Where?
I'm laying on a dead old lady.
Our drawers are empty, why'd you pick that drawer?
Something just dripped on me.
It's just a little dead man's fat. Necrotic liquid fat.
Now, will you stop being a baby.
That's it! I'm out.